schauen wir aber zuallererst auf unser
corona da das haben wir hier und da
sehen wir das so langsam nach diesem
plateau der sich gebildet hat es
vielleicht zu einem leichten rückgang
kommt denn die hohen ausschläge die
starken ausschläge sind nicht mehr so
stark 17.000 270 neue infektionen sind
trotzdem nach wie vor noch vermeldet für
die letzten 24 stunden das sind aber gut
3 1300 weniger als im am mittwoch
letzter woche also ist das die
trendwende wir werden sehen
die traurige nachricht auf jeden fall
des tages ist die zahl der toten in den
letzten 24 stunden 487 menschen sind mit
oder an corona in den letzten 24 stunden
gestorben und das ist ein neuer
trauriger rekord schauen wir auf die
korona hotspots diese landkreise sind
liegen nach wie vor über der inzidenz
von 200 nach wie vor sehr viele aber die
gute nachricht kein landkreis liegt mehr
über 500 also die stadt passau ist
zurückgefallen unter 500 ebenso
hildburghausen zurückgefallen und
nürnberg auch eine stadt wo ja
verschärfung stattfanden gestern
vorgestern glaube ich war das hat sich
die steigerung nicht mehr so ex
potenzial verbreitet und ausgebreitet
und erhöht aber trotzdem die stadt
passau und hildburghausen nach wie vor
führend in den landkreisen in den
hotspots in deutschland und noch ein
kurzer blick auf die intensivbetten von
den 27 1592 gemeldeten betten sind
bereits 22.000 121 belegt mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren